[موسيقى]
الحصاد معكم جلال شهده فالوقت الذي احدثكم
فيه احداث تقع وتتفاعلوا اخرى البدايه من
رام الله وهذه الصور المباشره في نهايه
يوم شهد تصعيدا كبيرا في الضفه شمل
اغتيالا من الجو لثلاثه فلسطينيين قرب
جنين واعتداءات كبيره من قبل المستوطنين
على ممتلكات الفلسطينيين في بلدتي ترمس
عيا شمال رام الله وعريف جنوب نابلس
من الخرطوم نتابع هذه الصور تزامنا مع
اشتباكات محترمه في العاصمه السودانيه
ومناطق اخرى بعد انتهاء هدنه استمرت
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه شهدت خروقات عديده
في مواضيع الحصاد
تصعيد واسع النطاق في الضفه الغربيه
اسرائيل تعلن تصفيه خليه قرب جنين
وتستهدفها بقصف من الجو في اول عمليه من
نوعها منذ 20 عاما وفي مشهد اخر بالضفه
الغربيه مئات المستوطنين يهاجمون بلدتي
ترمس
ويحرقون سيارات ومنازل
السلطه تدين حماس تتوعد بالتصعيد واشنطن
تعرب عن قلقها من عنف المستوطنين
يتهم اسرائيل بمساعده المستوطنين على
الافلات من العقاب
هدنه اخرى تنتهي في السودان وتترك مكانها
الاشتباكات ضاريه في الخرطوم مشهد
المواجهات يتعاقد مع دخول الجيش في
مواجهات مع الحركه الشعبيه قطع الشمال في
جنوب كردفان يقول ان واشنطن والرياض في
تواصل يومي مع طرفي الصراع لتسهيل ايصال
المساعدات
على واقع قتال عنيف في محور زبيروجيا حديث
عن محاوله مضاليين اوكرانيين اختراق
الدفاعات الروسيه روسيا تعلن احباط هجوم
بالمسيرات في منطقه موسكو وبوتين يقول ان
اوكرانيا لم تستنفذ قدراتها الهجوميه بعد
رغم تكبرها خسائر فادحه والاتحاد الاوروبي
يقر الحزمه الحاديه عشره من العقوبه على
موسكو
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا القلق المتزايد في تونس
بعد توقيف الصحفي زياد الهاني والانباء عن
اعتقاله بموجب مرسوم مكافحه الجرائم
الالكترونيه بعد تصريحات ادلى بها في
اذاعه محليه وذلك مع سلسله ملاحقات ضد
صحفيين باستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي كيف ترون
انعكاس اخضاع عدد لافت من الصحفيين
للتحقيقات والملاحقات على وضع حريه
التعبير والحريات العامه في تونس
73% صوتوا لصالح خيار مزيد من تقييد حريه
العمل الصحفي بينما قال 16% انما يحصل قد
يؤدي الى توتر بين النقابات والسلطه فيما
اعتبر احد عشر في المئه ان السلطه ستتراجع
عن المراسيم المقيده للتعبير الحر
هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهره على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودوليا
[موسيقى]
نبدا بتطورات المتلاحقه والتصعيد واسع
النطاق في الضفه الغربيه حيث قال مراسل
الجزيره ان جيش الاحتلال الاسرائيلي قصف
من الجو سياره تقل فلسطينيين شمالي مدينه
جنين قرب حاجز الجلم العسكري وقال الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه رصد سياره مشبوهه كانت تقل
افراد خليه فلسطينيه بعد تنفيذها عمليات
اطلاق نار وان ثلاثه مسلحين قتلوا في
الغاره التي نفذتها طائره مسيره واضاف
الجيش ان هذا الاسلوب في التصفيه من الجو
استخدم اخر مره في عام 2006 الدفاع المدني
الفلسطيني من جانبه قال انه عثر على ثلاث
جثث داخل المركبه وان قوات الاحتلال تنسق
مع الاسعاف الاسرائيلي
لاحتجاز جثامين شهداء القصف وليد العمري
مدير مكتب الجزيره انضم الينا من رام الله
وليد ما التفاصيل التي تكشفت حول هذا
الهجوم الاسرائيلي على سياره فلسطينيه
هذا الهجوم هو عمليه استهداف وتصفيه
اقدمها جيش الاحتلال من خلال طياره طائره
مسيره في حقل قرب ضاحيه صباح الخير بين
ضاحيه صباح الخير الشماليه للجنين وحاجز
الجلمه
وحسب دعايه فان من كان فيها قد كانوا قد
نفذوا عمليه اطلاق نار باتجاه هذه الجلمه
واقامت المسيره بعد ان تم رصد السياره
باطلاق صاروخ عليها ومما ادى الى اشتعال
النيران فيها وقال الدفاع المدني
الفلسطيني بانه عثر على ثلاث جثث متفحمه
لكن قوات الاحتلال منعت الجانب الفلسطيني
من استلام الجثث
واطلقت النيران حتى على المواطنين الذين
هرعوا الى تلك المنطقه وتوغلت لواء وقت
قصير في شارع الناصره الذي يصل الى
المشارف الشماليه لمدينه جنين هذا جرى في
الساعتين الماضيتين وتع هذه العمليه
الاولى من نوعها منذ نحو 17 عاما او اكثر
حيث كان قوات الاحتلال قد توقفت عن
استخدام الطائرات المسيره او عمليات القصف
من الجوف في عملياتها سواء لاحباط او
لتصفيه او الاغتيال نشطاء وقاده فلسطينيين
في الضفه الغربيه على وجه التحديد وركزت
ذلك على غزه لسنوات طويله هذا التطور ياتي
في خدام يوم واضح كان فيه الكثير من
الاعتداءات التي نفذتها ميليشيات وعصابات
المستوطنين والتي يرى الفلسطينيون وكثير
من الاسرائيليين انها تشكل جزءا في منظومه
الاحتلال وليست جزءا خارجا وانما جزءا
اصيلا فيه لان هذه المجموعات المسلحه كانت
قد اقتحمت واطلقت النيران واحرقت وعندما
بعد قليل من مغادرتها قدمت قوات الاحتلال
وقمعت الفلسطينيين الذين كانوا يحاولون
التصدي لها الاعتداءات تركزت بعد الظهر في
قريه ترمس عياد شمالي شرق مدينه رام الله
حيث سقط شهيدا هناك واحرقت العديد من
البيوت وايضا عشرات السيارات والحقول ومن
ثم في ساعاته الليل على بلده عريف جنوبي
مدينه نابلس وجاءت هذه الاعتداءات بشكل
جليل وواضح في وقت كان فيه المستوطنون
انفسهم قد وجهوا دعوات الى اتباعهم
وانصارهم عبر المجموعاتهم على الواتساب من
يعلنون فيها بانهم سينفذون مثل هذه
الهجمات بمعنى ان جيش الاحتلال واجهزه
الامنيه لا تستطيع ان تقول انها لم تكن
على علم بمثل هذه الامور ميليشيات
المستوطنين هذه تتواصلوا تواصلت ويبدو
انها ستتواصل المرحله المقبله الى جانب
ذلك اقدمت القياده الاسرائيليه وتباهت بان
ايضا زياده الاستيطان بالف وحده سكنيه
جديده علاوه على
ال4500 التي كانت قد اعلنت عنها يوم الاحد
الماضي وقبل قليل اعلنت السرايا القدس
الذراع العسكريه لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
كتيبه جنين بان الشهداء هم من كوادرها ومن
بين عناصرها وهم صهيب عدنان الغول ومحمد
بشار عويس واشرف مراد السعدي هؤلاء هم من
كانوا داخل السياره التي استهدفتها قوات
الاحتلال شكرا لك وليد العمري في رام الله
هذا تطور في جنين جاء بعد مشهد تصعيد اخر
في شمال رام الله حيث هاجم مئات
المستوطنين بلده ترمسيه واحرقوا سيارات
ومنازل قبل ان يقتحم جيش الاحتلال البلده
ويقتل شابا فلسطينيا اثر مواجهات
والاعتداء من مستوطنين متطرفين بحمايه
جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في بلده ترمسيه
الشماليه مدينه رام الله
جنود الاحتلال اطلقوا الرصاص وقنابل الغاز
على الفلسطينيين
مما ادى الى وقوع شهيد واصابه
[موسيقى]
الله يرحمك الله يرحمك
عمر الشهيد الله يرحمه اول واحد اول واحد
المستوطنين من الجيش بلشوا عليه طخ الله
يرحمك يا ابو عمي الله يرحمك
مساحات واسعه من مزارع الفلسطينيين في
البلده طالتها ايضا حرائق المستوطنين هذه
اثار اعتداءات المستوطنين في قرى وبلدات
فلسطينيه وتحديدا في جنوب مدينه نابلس
ومحيطها احنا كنا محتمين في سياراتنا لما
اجوا علينا طمعان اجوا الشباب اخذونا في
بيوتهم واجهوا مستوطنين على مرة ومسمع
الجيش الاسرائيلي والشرطه الاسرائيليه
يطالب الفلسطينيون المجتمع الدولي باجبار
الحكومه الاسرائيليه ومستوطنيها على وقف
ما يصفونه بالارهاب المنظم في حقهم
مشاهدوا احراق ممتلكات الفلسطينيين في
ترموسعيه وفي عده قرى المجاوره تدل على ان
قانون يردع المستوطنين المتطرفين من
السباحه ما هو فلسطيني فاعتداءاتهم تمت
بحمايه جنود الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وبتجاهل
حكومته المواقف الدوليه حيال ما يت
الفلسطينيون ليل الفلسطينيين كنهارهم
المستوطرون يحرقون ممتلكات الفلسطينيين
وجاءت هذه الاحداث الاخيره بعد مقتل
واصابه مستوطنين في عمليه نفذها شابان
فلسطينيان في احدى محطات الوقود قرب
مستوطنه عيله بين مدينتينا بسوارام الله
وهي العمليه نفسها التي جاءت بعد اقتحام
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي جنين وما نتج
عنه من استشهاد واصابات وتدمير سمير ابو
شمالي الجزيره من بلده ترمس علي الشماليه
رام الله فلسطين
وفي اخبار عاجله سرايا القدس كتيبه جنين
تقول نزف ثله من ابطالنا في جريمه اغتيال
جبانه نفذتها طائره مسيره لجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وفي ايضا خبر عاجل اخر القناه
الرابعه عشر الاسرائيليه تقول التغيير في
سياسه الاغتيالات جوا جاء بدعم من يوقف
جالنت وموافقه بنيامين نتنياهو بعد معارضه
الجيش الاسرائيلي نتابع في سياق اخبارنا
وبعد ساعات من مهاجمه ترمس عيا اقدم
مستوطنون في وجود قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيليه على اقتحام بلده عريف جنوبيه
نابلس وقالت السلطات المحليه في المنطقه
ان المستوطنين قاموا برشق المنازل
بالحجاره واكد رئيس المجلس البلدي اصابه
عدد من المواطنين بينهم طفل بحالات اختناق
جراء اطلاق قوه الاحتلال قنابل غاز لتفريق
فلسطينيين خرجوا للتصدي لاعتداءات
المستوطنين
هذا ودانه الخارجيه الفلسطينيه ما وصفته
بانفلات عصابات المستوطنين من اي قانون او
رادع وفي اشاره الى ما حدث اليوم في ترمس
عيا قالت الخارجيه ان جريمه حوارات تتكرر
من جديد وان ميليشيا المستوطنين ومنظماتهم
الارهابيه المسلحه توسع دائره هجماتها على
الفلسطينيين المدنيين العزل وممتلكاتهم
ومزروعاتهم واكدت الخارجيه انها تبذل
جهودها مع الدول لحثها على اعتماد منظمات
المستوطنين التي ترتكب الجرائم على قوائم
الارهاب
جاتها وصفت حركه حماس اعتداءات المستوطنين
على ترمسيه وبلدات الضفه الغربيه بالجريمه
البشعه واعتبرت الحركه ان الاعتداء على
ترمسيه يشكل تصعيدا خطيرا وجريمه بشعه
تجري بتحريض ودعم من حكومه الاحتلال محمله
اياها المسؤوليه عن تداعياتها واكدت
الحركه ان هذه الجرائم لن ترهب الشعب
الفلسطيني وستقابل بمزيد من الصمود وتصعيد
المقاومه والتصدي للاحتلال ومستوطنيه في
كل انحاء الضفه الغربيه
واكد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو ان حكومته لن تسمح بما وصفها
باعمال شغب في اي مكان وقال نتنياهو ان
مواطني اسرائيل ملزمون باحترام القانون
مشددا على دعمه للشرطه الاسرائيليه في
عملياتها
انا امنح كامل الدعم لشرطه اسرائيل وقوات
الامن في عملياتهم الراميه الى تطبيق
القانون واحلال النظام لن نقبل ان يتحد ضد
الشرطه وقوى الامن في اي مكان نحن دوله
قانون
جاتها ذكرت القناه الاسرائيليه الثانيه
عشره ان وزير الامن القومي اعتمار بنكفير
جدد مطالبته بشن عمليه عسكريه واسعه في
الضفه الغربيه ورحب بنكفير في لقاء مع
نتنياهو بالاعلان عن التصديق على مخطط
بناء الف وحده استيطانيه جديده في مستوطنه
عيله وسط الضفه الغربيه
هذا وقالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ان هناك
تقارير مثيره للقلق بشان عنف المستوطنين
المتطرفين ضد المدنيين الفلسطينيين بما في
ذلك وفاه طفل فلسطيني وعدد من الجرحى
واكدت الوزاره انها تشعر بقلق بالغ من
تصاعد مستويات العنف في الضفه الغربيه
خلال الاشهر الماضيه ودانت الخارجيه
الامريكيه الاعمال العنيفه حسب تعبيرها
واعتبرت ان الاجراءات الاحاديه كتوسيع
المستوطنات ستؤدي الى اثاره التوترات
وتقويض حل الدولتين كما دانت مسمته الهجوم
الارهابيه ضد اسرائيليين بالقرب من عيله
بالضفه الغربيه
من رام الله دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي الامين
العام لحركه المبادره الوطنيه الفلسطينيه
من الناصره ايهاب جبارين الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه ومن واشنطن السفير بيجي
كراولي المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه
الامريكيه مرحبا بكم جميعا دكتور مصطفى
اولا ماذا تقرا في هذا التطور الاسرائيلي
عوده الاغتيالات جوا بمسيرات او بطائرات
بعد توقف هذه العمليات لنحو 20 عاما في
الضفه الغربيه
الذي يجري امر في غايه الخطوره اخطر حتى
من شن عمليه عسكريه الذي يجري هو ان جيش
الاحتلال وحكام الاحتلال المجرمين
يستخدموا سياسه مزدوجه من جانب يستعمل جيش
الاحتلال بكل قوته العسكريه الطائرات الاف
16 الاباتشي الطائرات المسيره كل الطائرات
الحربيه والمدرعات العسكريه ضد شعب يعيش
تحت الاحتلال ضد مدنيين في الاساس يعيشون
تحت الاحتلال وهذا الى جانب استخدامهم
للمستوطنين الارهابيين العنصريين الذين
شنوا منذ امس وحتى اليوم اكثر من 50 عمليه
هجوم على قرى فلسطينيه امنه استخدموا وهم
مسلحون وبحمايه جيش الاحتلال لم يقم جيش
الاحتلال باعتقال مستوطن واحد من هؤلاء لم
يطلق عليهم الرصاص بل اطلق الرصاص على
الضحايا على الفلسطينيين الذين يتعرضوا
لهذه الهجمات الارهابيه
الذي يجري امر خطير جدا لم يقم به من قبل
الا النازيون والفشيون في العالم ان يشنوا
حرب جيش وعصابات ارهابيه على شعب تحت
الاحتلال وهم الذين يحتلونه هذا لم يحدث
من قبل الا من قبل الفاشين والنازيين ولكن
دعني اقول لك هذا من ناحيه يدل على
الوقاحه والغطرسه والاجرام ولكن يدل ايضا
على الفشل الفشل اسرائيل في كسر المقاومه
الفلسطينيه الباسله فشل اسرائيل في كسر
اراده الشعب الفلسطيني على النضال والكفاح
والمقاومه وما سيرونه هو مزيد من هذه
المقاومه وليس تراجعا من الشعب الفلسطيني
ولكن اليوم اذا يكافي ما نقلت هذه الهجمات
من المستوطنين في ظل زياده التحريض على
الضفه الغربيه والمطالبه بشن عمليه عسكريه
واسعه وكما تابعنا اليوم ايضا عمليه
اغتيال بالجو لاول مره منذ حوالي 20 عاما
مما الات هذا التصعيد
العمليه العسكريه بدات ما قاموا به
باستخدام طائرات الاف 16 والطائرات
المسيره في
الاباتشي في مخيم جنين قبل يومين وما
قاموا به اليوم من استخدام للطائرات
المسيره لعمليه الاغتيال يعني ان العمليه
العسكريه بدات وانهم بداوا باستخدام الجيش
بكل طاقته وقوته ولكن هذا يؤدي الى سيؤدي
الى انتفاضه شعبيه فلسطينيه شامله لانه
ليس امام الفلسطينيين الا ان يدافعوا
بالمقاومه عن انفسهم وعن اطفالهم وعن
ابنائهم وعن مستقبلهم وعن حقهم في الحريه
والتخلص من هذا الاحتلال المجرم ومن نظام
التمييز العنصري ومن هؤلاء المستوطنين
الارهابيين الذين يشكلون خطرا على كل
فلسطين يوافق على كل فلسطينيه ولكن ايضا
المطلوب فلسطينيين المطلوب اليوم ان يتوحد
الجميع في قياده موحده امام هذا الارهاب
الصهيوني انا لا ارى فرقا بين المستعمرين
الارهابيين
الا خيار واحد برايي ان ارادت ان تستجيب
لاراده شعبها ولمطالب شعبها وهذا الخيار
قطع العلاقات مع هؤلاء المجرمين المحتلين
التحلل من هذه الاتفاقيات الاجراميه
التوقف من المراهقه على المراهنه على
اوهام المفاوضات وغيرها والتوحد مع كل
القوى الفلسطينيه في قياده وطنيه موحده
على برنامج وطني كفاحي مقاوم والغاء
التنسيق الامني بكل اشكاله من المعيب ان
يكون هناك تنسيق امني ونحن نشهد هذه
الاعتداءات على الشعب الفلسطيني من
الارهابيين المستوطنين ومن جيش الاحتلال
المجرم
شكرا لك دكتور مصطفى البرغوثي اتحول الى
الناصره مع السيد ايهاب جبارين الخبير في
الشؤون الاسرائيليه سيد ايهاب نريد ان
نعرف يبدو ان هناك خبرا عاجلا مع الاسف
انا لا استطيع ان ارى الشاشه نعم
سرايا القدس
كتيبه جنين
تقول بان الاغتيالات لن تنال من عزيمتنا
وعلى قياده العدو تحمل العقاب اذا هذا
الخبر العاجل الذي ورد الان انطلاقا من
هنا سيد ايهاب نريد ان نفهم كيف يفكر الان
الاسرائيلي وقد استانف عمليه الاغتيال من
الجو بمسيره
نعم مساء الخير عم بطبيعه الحال
الاجهزه الامنيه العسكريه الاسرائيليه
كانت تحاول ان يعني تغير بعض الشيء اي
مشهد اقتحامي تتوغل فيه في داخل الضفه
الغربيه تدخل اليه ربما قد لا تعرف كيف
تخرج منها يعني بدلالات ما معها يوم امس
في جنين حتى قبله يعني من مشاهد اقتحامات
التي كانت تقوم بها وفي نهايه المطاف تخرج
بها بخسائر كهذه او بشكل اخر يمكن القول
انها يعني
المعادله باتت واضحه اليها بان كل اقتحام
لداخل الضفه داخل الضفه الغربيه سوف يجابه
بعمليات للمقاومه الفلسطينيه بالتالي وهذه
المعادله يعني اثبتت واقعها واثبتت
فعاليتها امام الاجهزه الامنيه العسكريه
لكن ومع ذلك يعني كما يقال في الدرجه
الفلسطينيه ضربتين في الراس توجا فما بالك
الان الاجهزه الامنيه تتعامل مع جنيد
تتعامل مع ايلين تتعامل مع حتى اختراقات
الحدود التي كانت في مصر وفي لبنان وقبلها
يعني
شبه الخساره التي كانت في العدوان على غزه
بالتالي هي تتعمل مع مفهوم واحد الذي منذ
بدايه هذا العام ومع استهلال هذه الحكومه
لمناصبها اليه الردع هي تعلم ان هذه
المنظومه وهذه المفهوم هي بحاجه لكي تضع
يدها العليا عليه
وتسوقه جيدا
لما تسميهم باعدائهم فبالتالي وفق هذه
المعادله الان هي تحاول ان ترسم التكتيكات
بات واضحا لديها ان لديها يعني هذا وفق
الكثير من التقارير التي نشرها
الان وقد نشرت الاسماء كتيبه جنين تقول
نزف الشهداء القائد الميداني صهيب الغول
واشرف السعدي من سرايا القدس ومحمد عويس
مشهداء الاقصى ماذا تقرا في هذه الاسماء
اتوقع ان يكون هنالك رد من قبل
الفصائل الفلسطينيه وتحديدا سرايا القدس
بكل ما يخص هذه العمليه هذا كذلك تتوقعه
قوات الاحتلال وهذه الجزئيه مهمه جدا اظن
ان الرد بالتالي سوف يكون على المحل
والاقتحامات لن يسعدها هي بحاجه بالذات
لهذه التكتيك وهذه الاستراتيجيه
استراتيجيه
ضربات يكون فيها
يد العليا لها باقل اضرار ممكنه وبدون
ادنى شك ان التكنولوجيا والتفوق العسكري
والاعتاد العسكري هو الذي يميز يعني في
نهايه المطاف جيش الاحتلال على ارض الواقع
هذا يعني هذا ما كنت اريد في نهايه المطاف
في النقطه الاخيره ان هنالك اشكاليه مع
جوده الجنود اذا وضعنا جانبا وحدتين
وجولاني وغيرهما من الوحدات الخاصه
بالوحدات المشاه بشكل يومي هنالك العاديه
والاعتياديه هنالك مشكله بجودتها في نهايه
الكثير من التقارير وبالتالي هي لا يعني
تعيل عليها في في مثل هذه الاقتحمات لذلك
هي بحاجه لتكتي اشبه بالكغ والفار وهي
تعلم جيدا ان لا يوجد اي مجال الاجهزه
الامنيه العسكريه بعيدا عن السياسيه واذا
حتى بالسياسيه يمكن القول فقط اصمت من هذا
المشهد هنالك شبه اجماع انهم بحاجه لضباط
قصيره موجه هذا التكتيك الذي سوف تستهله
اسرائيل في هذه المرحله طيب شكرا لك سيدي
ايهاب جبارين الخبير في الشؤون
الاسرائيليه
ونتحول الى واشنطن مع السفير بيجي كراولي
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
سيد كراولي حتى قبل تشكيل هذه الحكومه
كانت اداره الرئيس بايدن تحذر من تصعيد
محتمل
باعتقادك الان وقد حصل هذا التصعيد الذي
كانت تتخوف منه الاداره الامريكيه كيف
تراقب ما يجري على الارض في فلسطين
المحتله
الحقيقه الخطر الذي توقعناها قد حصل
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يمكن ان نقول انها
تسعى لهذا النوع من المواجهات من اجل
تعزيز موقفها على المستوى السياسي الداخلي
المعضله بالنسبه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هي ان التاثير الامريكي على
الحكومه الاسرائيليه محدود وان حكومه
نتنياهو برايها ترى ان هذه المواجهه سوف
تسمح لها بالبقاء وبالتالي الرد الامريكي
محدود التاثير المحدود سيبقى ضمن الرد
المحدود ام انه ممكن لانه
موقف للخارجيه الامريكيه بنبره مرتفعه
اكثر من العاده فيما يتعلق بالمستوطنات
وهجوم المستوطنين هل سيبقى الموقف
الامريكي ضمن هذا الاطار بيجيكراولي ام
انه سيواكب بالضروره هذا التصعيد الحاصل
على الارض
اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن تحديين اساسيين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انتقدت بشكل
كبير قرار حكومه نتنياهو الاخير بتوسيع
الاستيطان الاسرائيلي وقالت ذلك الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه في تصريحات علنيه وخلف
الابواب المغلقه لربما الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يمكنها ان تؤثر في هذا المجال
الى حد ما ومن جهه اخرى لدينا
يمكننا ان نقول بشكل شهري توترات فعل من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه رد فعل من حماس
المستوطنون يستفيدون من هذه الامور
وينتهزوها فرصه للقيام باعمال اخرى
وبالتالي هذا التصعيد المتزايد لا يمكن اي
طرف ان يؤثر عليه وهذا بالتحديد هو الخطر
ان تنفلت الامور في مرحله معينه وهذا يؤدي
بنا الى الوصول الى ماساه للشعب الفلسطيني
والاسرائيليين اذا الخارجيه الامريكيه
تقول نشعر بقلق بالغ من تصاعد مستويات
العنف في الضفه الغربيه خلال الاشهر
الماضيه انطلاقا طبعا من ما حصل اليوم
ايضا تابعنا مواقف مثلا للسفير البريطاني
في في فلسطين في القدس تبعنا ايضا موقف
لجوتيرش امين عام
الامين العام
انطونيو غوتارش فيما يتعلق ايضا
بالاستيطان هل يبدو لك بان موقفا دوليا
بدا يتشكل بشكل اوضح لوقف هذه الممارسات
خاصه ما يتعلق بهجوم المستوطنين على قرى
فلسطينيه
في الحقيقه ارى ان هناك توافق اراء على
المستوى الدولي بالنسبه الى المستوطنات
وان هذه المستوطنات تزيد الطين بلا
بالنسبه الى عرقله الحلول الممكنه ولكن في
حقيقه الامر ما من حلول بعيده المدى ما
رايناه في الايام القليله المقبله يتطلب
استجابه استراتيجيه ولكنها ليست بمقدوري
الجانب الفلسطيني او الجانب الاسرائيلي ما
نحن بحاجه اليه هو حل دائم حدود واضحه
للدوله الفلسطينيه ولكن مالات هذه الامور
ولا يمكننا ان نرى في حقيقه الامر الى اين
سوف تصل الامور بهذا الاتجاه وهناك محاوله
لمنع التصعيد بشكل
كرر هذا ما يتم ولكن ما من افاق باتجاه حل
دائم هذه المعضله التي تواجهها الولايات
المتحده والاسره الدوليه الان ونحن نتحدث
السفير بيجيكراولي ممثل الاتحاد الاوروبي
لعمليه السلام يقول
منزعج من تزايد العنف ضد المدنيين في
الاراضي المحتله وانعدام
المساءله قلت في معرض اجابتك الاولى قلت
بان هذه الحكومه حكومه نتنياهو تسعى لهذا
النوع من المواجهات بتقديرك وبخبرتك
السياسيه الطويله والدبلوماسيه لان ممكن
ان تذهب هذه الحكومه في ممارساتها ضد
الفلسطينيين لتحقيق ماربها السياسيه
المتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه
كنت معنا في واشنطن نتابع الان هذه الصور
لمسيره في رام الله تمديدا بالانتهاكات
التي تطال المدن الاسرائيليه المدن
الفلسطينيه عفوا لا سيما من قبل
المستوطنين الاسرائيليين في عريف وايضا في
ترمس عيا وما حصل في جنين بطبيعه الحال
اذا نتابع الان هذه الصور المباشره لهذه
المسيره في رام الله المندده بالاعتداءات
والانتهاكات للجيش الاسرائيلي وللمستوطنين
الاسرائيليين على مناطق وقرى فلسطينيه
نحاول ان نستمع سويا لهذه الصرخات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يرحب
اذا تابعنا هذه المسيره في رام الله
المندده لما يتعرض له الفلسطينيون في
قراهم ومنازلهم وايضا في اراضيهم الزراعيه
نعود لاستكشاف كيف كان المشهد اليوم خصوصا
فيما يتعلق باعتداءات المستوطنين في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله
من لا يتذكر او يعرف ما سات عائله دوابش
الفلسطينيه قبل ثمان سنوات احرق مستوطنون
منزل وقتلوا رجلا وزوجته وطفلهما الرضيع
لم تكن هذه المجزره اول ولا اخر اعتداءات
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه ما حصل في
حواره قبل اشهر قليله وما جرى في ترمس عيا
اليوم حلقات في مسلسل الاعتداءات المتواصل
بالارقام مثلا للحصر ارتكب المستوطنون
خلال الشهر الماضي وحده اكثر من 500
اعتداء تنوعت بين القتل واحراق المنازل
والممتلكات واقتلاع الاشجار والاعتداءات
الجسديه ارقام وصور صادمه تعكس العقليه
التي يحملها هؤلاء المستوطنون من اكثرهم
تطرفا وتصدرا للمشهد جماعه فتيه التلال هم
المتهمون باحراق عائله الدوابشه ومحاولات
كثيره لتكرار الجريمه هكذا يشكل الاستيطان
في الضفه الغربيه دوله شبه مكتمله الاركان
اكثر من 700 الف موزعين على اكثر من 300
مستوطنه وبكره استيطانيه في المناطق
المصنفه جيم بحسب اتفاق اوسلو اكبرها
واشهرها مستوطنات عاليه
لكن الضفه مليئه بعشره مستوطنات متفاوته
الاحجام ينتشر فيها جماعات كثيره مثل فتيه
التلال
تلك جماعات ترعاها اوساط رسميه في اسرائيل
ابرزهم وزير الامن القومي
عندما يقال ان الحكومه الحاليه هي حكومه
المستوطنين فهذا ما يعنيه الامر ليس فقط
بقرارات التوسع الاستيطاني غير المسبوق بل
بالرعايه شبه الرسميه من الحكومه لافعاله
هؤلاء المستوطنين اخر هذه الرعايات
الرسميه تشكيل الحرس الوطني ورقه وضعها
بنكفير على طاوله الحكومه شرطا لعدم
انهيارها في مواجهه الاحتجاجات يقوم الحرس
الوطني الذي يقوده الوزير المتطرف بشكل
اساسيا على ما يصفه بمكافحه الارهاب تلك
وظيفه تعني دمج المستوطنين المسلحين في
المؤسسه الامنيه الاسرائيليه بشكل رسمي
يعني ان يتحول فتيه التلال حارقه عائله
الدوابش والقرى الفلسطينيه الى جنود وضباط
يقتلون ويحرقون باسم الدوله كما يخشى
الفلسطينيون ذلك امر يعيد اسرائيل الى اصل
منشائها عصابات متطرفه تعيد المجازر من
التاريخ الى المستقبل
[موسيقى]
مشاهد اعتداءات المستوطنين على
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه تعيد الى
الواجهه الازمه التي يشكلها الاستيطان في
ظل الدعم الحكومي الاسرائيلي للاستيطان في
فقره المتابعه نحاول رسم خريطه نقاط
الاحتكاك تاريخيا وتلك الاكثر اشتعالا في
هذه الايام بلده ترمس عيا الواقعه وسط
الضفه الغربيه في منتصف الطريق الرئيسي
الرابط بين رام الله ونابلس تعرضت البلده
يوم الاربعاء لهجوم عنيف من مستوطنين
احرقوا عددا من المنازل والمركبات استشهد
فيها شاب فلسطيني برصاص جنود الاحتلال كما
عادت الى الواجهه بلده حواره بين نابلس
ورام الله اذ هاجم نحو 100 مستوطن سكانها
واضرب النار في ارض زراعيه وعاده ما ينطلق
المهاجمون من مستوطنه يتسار المجاوره
المستوطنون هاجموا ايضا قريتي اللبان
الشرقيه
فوريك التابعتين لمحافظه نابلس واحرقوا
سيارات وحقولا زراعيه بلدات بالعين ونعلين
والنبي صالح في رام الله هي ايضا نقاط
مواجهه حيث يحاول المستوطنون بحمايه جيش
الاحتلال الاستيلاء على اراضيها لاستكمال
بناء الجدار الفاصل الذي يعزل تلك البلدات
عن محيطها كما يعتبر قبر النبي يوسف في
الجزء الشرقي من مدينه نابلس بؤره احتكاك
بسبب اقتحام المستوطنين له بزعم انه مكان
مقدس لليهود وفي محافظه الخليل يتعرض
اهالي قرى منطقه يطا لاعتداءات متكرره من
المستوطنين على ممتلكاتهم حيث اقام
الاحتلال عده مستوطنات وبؤره استيطانيه
على اراضي الفلسطينيه
هجمات المستوطنين على الفلسطينيين يوازيها
مد استيطاني متسارع يقابل حتى الان بردود
فعل دوليه متواضعه الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش اكد ان جميع
المستوطنات الاسرائيليه في الضفه الغربيه
المحتله بما في ذلك القدس الشرقيه ليس لها
اي شرعيه قانونيه وحث غوتيرش اسرائيل على
وقف جميع الانشطه الاستيطانيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي اعلن انه يجدد معارضته الشديده
القائمه منذ زمن طويل لسياسه الاستيطان
الاسرائيليه ودعا اسرائيل الى عدم المضي
قدما في خطتها الاستيطانيه لانها تتعارض
مع الحاجه الى ضمان الهدوء ونزع فتيل
التوترات اما الخارجيه الامريكيه فقالت في
بيان انها منزعجه بشده من اعلان الحكومه
الاسرائيليه المضي قدما في بناء اربعه
الاف وحده استيطانيه جديده وشجبت الخارجيه
التركيه مشروعه اسرائيل لانشاء مستوطنات
جديده وشددت على ان تلك الخطوات
غير مقبوله وهي تتعارض بالكامل مع القانون
الدولي ومواثيق الامم المتحده تنضم الينا
من واشنطن السيده فيليس بنس مديره مشروع
العولمه الجديده في معهد الدراسات
السياسيه سيده بنس كيف ترين الدعم الحكومي
الواضح والسافر
لزياده الاستيطان على اراض فلسطينيه
السؤال الاساسي بالنسبه الى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ليس اذا ما عبرت عن
قلقها بل اذا ما كانت مستعده على تغيير
لتغيير سياسه حتى الان ليس هذا هو الحال
عندما انتخب الرئيس بايدن اوضح بشكل لا
لبس فيه انه لا يتفق مع الموقف المتشدد
الذي اعتمدته اداره ترامب بدعم هذه
المواقف المتطرفه في اسرائيل على سبيل
المثال نقل السفاره الى القدس والقول ان
المستوطنات هي شرعيه وقانونيه والضم هي
سياسه مناسبه اذا هو لم يتفق مع ترامب في
ذلك ولكنه لم يغير السياسه الامريكيه
والتصريحات الامريكيه بالتعبير عن المخاوف
والتحدث عن ان هذه المستوطنات تعرقل عمليه
السلام هذه تصريحات قديمه لا تصل الى وصف
هذه المستوطنات بغير القانونيه التالي حتى
نرى التغيرات في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه بناء على عدم قانونيه
المستوطنات وعنف المستوطنين الذي يتم
التصعيد في هذا المجال بشكل كبير حتى نرى
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تحاسب او تسمح بمحاسبه اسرائيل على مستوى
الامم المتحده وعلى المستوى الدولي هذه
التصريحات لا تعني الكثير
ضيوفنا قبل قليل قالوا بان الخطير بان هذه
الحكومه حكومه نتنياهو تستخدم الاستيطان
للبقاء في السلطه ولم شمل هذه المجموعات
المتطرفه الداعمه لحكومه نتنياهو في هذه
المرحله على الاقل ما خطوره هذا بتقديرك
هذا في غايه الخطوره في حقيقه الامر حيث
ان نتنياهو لديه اسباب خاصه للبقاء في
السلطه حيث انه يود ان يبقى خارج السجن
على الارجح اذا ما لم يعد رئيسا لمجلس
الوزراء الاسرائيلي سوف ينتهي به المطاف
في السجن وطالما انه ينخرط في عمل في سده
رئاسه مجلس الوزراء هو لديه هذه الحصانه
وبالتالي نتنياهو لديه مصلحه شخصيه وهذا
ما ظهر في حزبه نتنياهو هو في اليمين
ولكنه في حقيقه الامر يمثل اليسار في
تحالفها وفي ائتلافه الائتلاف هو اليمين
واليمين المتطرف واقصى اليمين واليمين
الفاشي ولقد اعطى سلطه متزايده لاكثر
المتطرفين بما في ذلك القرار المرتبط
بالتوسع الاستيطاني والعمليات الاستيطانيه
وبناء وحدات استيطانيه جديده ونحن نتحدث
هنا ليس فقط عن احتلال بل عن نظام فصل
عنصري يحتل الاراضي الفلسطينيه في هذا
السياق ومع سيطره المتطرفين اخشى ان الوضع
الذي يواجهه الفلسطينيون هو سوف يستمر بان
يصبح اسوا بالنسبه الى عنف المستوطنين
وتوسع الوحدات الاستيطانيه كما اشرتم
4500 وحده استطانيه جديده سوف تستحدث وفقا
للمخطط وبالتالي في هذا السياق هذا القص
تحديدا ما هي الخيارات
امام هذا الواقع وقلت بان
ردود الفعل الغربيه خاصه
الامريكي ليست على المستوى المطلوب وغير
كافيه امام هذا الواقع توسيع الاستيطان
هجوم من المستوطنين بحمايه الشرطه على
منازل المدنيين الفلسطينيين ما الذي يتركه
من خيارات امام الفلسطينيين والسلطه
الفلسطينيه
واقد ان الخيارات هي بين ايدي المجتمع
الدولي في حقيقه الامر حيث ان
الفلسطينيين ليسوا على قدم المساواه مع
الاسرائيليين لا نتحدث عن حكومتين لدولتين
لديهما سياده وهناك مسائل ومشاكل مرتبطه
بترسيم الحدود مثلا بل نحن نتحدث عن شعب
محتل يعاني من نظام فصل عنصري هذا من جهه
ومن جهه اخرى لدينا حكومه اسرائيليه في
غايه القوه مدعومه من قبل اغنى واقوى
الحكومات في العالم وخصوصا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه الولايات المتحده التي
تدفع 20% من الميزانيه العسكريه
الاسرائيليه هذا السياق يتطلب اجراءات على
مستوى الدولي ما اشرتم اليه اعلان السيد
بوتيرش عن ان هذه الامور هي عقبه او
عراقيل امام حاله دولتين هذا لا يكفي حيث
انه لا يمكننا ان نتحدث عن حل الدولتين
عندما تكون 60% من الاراضي في الضفه
الغربيه مسيطر عليها من قبل الاسرائيليين
يجب ان يتغير ذلك واعتقد اننا بدانا نشهد
تغيرا في الخطاب الامريكي تدريجيا يسمح
للحكومه الامريكيه ان تغير في سياساتها في
المستقبل راينا تغيرا في استطلاع الاراء
استطلاعات الراي وبشكل متزايد في الكونجرس
على سبيل المثال في العام 2021 عند
الاعتداء الاسرائيلي ضد غزه لدينا اثني
عشر
عضو في مجلس الشيوخ من اليهود كتبوا
وخاطبوا الرئيس بايدن لكي يحثوه على
الدعوه الى وقف لاطلاق النار
شكرا لك السيده فيليس فينيس مديره مشروع
العولمه الجديده في معهد الدراسات
السياسيه في واشنطن شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
اتابع من تطورات الوضع في السودان هدنه
تلوى اخرى ولا يتغير المشهد معارك محتدمه
على اكثر من جبهه في العاصمه وخارجها لكن
الموقف الميداني في السودان شهد التطورا
لافتا تمثل في تشعب جبهات القتال مع دخول
قوات من الحركه الشعبيه قطاع الشمال
بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو في مواجهات مع
قوه الجيش فقد افاد مصدر بالجيش السوداني
للجزيره بان قوات من الحركه هاجمت مدينه
الدلنج بولايه جنوب كردفان فجر اليوم وان
الحركه كانت تحشد قواتها منذ اكثر من
اسبوع للهجوم على المدينه
[موسيقى]
من يقاتل من عرف الطرفان منذ لحظه تفجر
الصراع كان سهلا ساعتها اختزال قتال الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في ان السلطه
مبتغاه مضت شهور على محنه السودان استعصى
فيها الحل تماما مثل ما استعصى الحسم على
اي من الطرفين
ومع اتساع رقعه القتال وترسخ حاله
الانقسام بدا الان ان الازمه تتشعب وتتعقد
فما سماها متابعون حرب الجنرالين تستهوي
كما يبدو مزيدا من حمله السلاح
يرصد متابعه المشهد السوداني هنا خروج
جماعات المسلحه مما يصفونها بدائره
الانتظار المتحفز
قد لا يتبدى ذلك بجلاء في مثلث العاصمه
الخرطوم ام درمان بحري لكن في جزء من
الولايات التي طاولها النزاع دخلت اطراف
جديده على خط المواجهه مع الطرفين
الرئيسيين مدفوعه اساسا باعتبارات الاثنيه
وتاريخيه اكثر القتال ضلاوه ما يزال يسجل
في مدن غرب السودان باقليم دارفور الذي
يشهد صراعا متقطعا منذ بدايه القرن الحالي
هناك حيث السلاح المستشري وحيث القاعده
الشعبيه لقوات الدعم السريع وهناك يخشى
الناس من ان تجدد النزاع على اساس عرقي
بين القبائل العربيه والافريقيه كما حدث
العام الماضي قد يقود الى حرب اهليه في
الاقليم مضطرب
لن يكون مستبعدا ساعتها وفقا لمحللين
انخراط الجماعات المسلحه سواء للموقعه ام
غير الموقعه على اتفاق السلام في القتال
اما بقرار من قادتها او من العناصر
المقاتله
في ولايه جنوب كردفان تجليا اخر لزاع يغرم
مزيدا من المسلحين من بين المتحفزين كما
يصفهم مراقبون نجد الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير
السودان شمال بقياده عبد العزيز الحلو
الحركه رفضت الانضمام الى اتفاق جوبا
للسلام الموقع العام الماضي بين الحكومه
الانتقاليه ومجموعه من الحركات المسلحه
لكنها موقعه على اتفاق لوقف اطلاق النار
مع حكومه حمدوك ذاتها منذ نحو ثلاثه اعوام
برعايه دوله جنوب السودان
وان يكن فان حركه الحلو لا تتردد الان في
مهاجمه مواقع الجيش السوداني ووحداته في
جنوب كردفان مستغله انشغاله بمعارك
الخرطوم سجلت اخيرا سلسله حوادث من ذلك
القبيل انها وغيرها تدق وفقا لمراقبين جرس
انذار لكافه الاطراف السودانيه ان احذروا
من وقوع البلد في حرب طويله متشابكه
ومعقده
اذا وقال مصدر سوداني مطلع للجزيره ان
الجيش السوداني والدعم السريع يبحثان في
جده هدنه جديده مطوله متعلقه بعيد الاضحى
من ناحيته كشف وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه ان
الولايات المتحده والسعوديه مستمرتان في
التواصل مع الاطراف السودانيه بشكل يومي
لتسهيل ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه
مع هنا في الاستوديو الدكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم الكاتب والمحل السياسي السوداني
دكتور مرحبا بك كيف ترى دخول قوات من
الحركه الشعبيه قطاع الشمال في هذا المشهد
مشهد القتال وفي مواجهه مع الجيش السوداني
هذه ليست المره الاولى حيث توغلت الحركه
الشعبيه لتحرير السودان في مناطق للجيش
السوداني خلال الايام الماضيه عده مرات
على الرغم من سريان اتفاق لاطلاق النار ظل
يتجدد على عده سنوات
الحركه الشعبيه لتحرير السودان ضدت بان
بعض من هذه الهجمات تمت بواسطه متفلتين
عليها مثلما تردد اليوم عن هجوم على مدينه
الدلج الدلنج تم بواسطه منشق عن الحركه
اسمه سنفور ولكن الجيش السوداني اصدر
بيانا اليوم واعلن فيه ان الحركه الشعبيه
لتحرير السودان هي التي هاجمت اللواء 54
صد الهجوم كثيرون تحدثوا عن ان الحركه
الشعبيه لتحرير السودان تريد ان تستغل
الانشغال الجيش السوداني في حربه مع
متمرديه دعم السريع لتحقيق مكاسب ميدانيه
ومن الامر ليس مرتبطا بدعم جهه مقابل
الجيش السوداني بكل تاكيد اتهمت الحركه
الشعبيه بانها تريد ان تخفف الضغط على
قوات الدعم السريع مع ان هذه القوات ظلت
تمثل
خصما تاريخيا للحركه الشعبيه ودخلت معها
فيما سبق في معارك عديده وانها تريد ان
تستغل هذا الظرف
توظف انشغال الجيش السوداني بحربه الممتده
له انعكاسات ميدانيه بتقديرك على على اداء
الجيش في مناطق اخرى الجيش اعلن انه تمكن
من كل الهجومات التي تمت على المناطق
المحيطه بكادوقلي
الجنوب كردفان طيب يتم البحث الان في جده
عن هدنه ربما اطول من المعتاد متعلقه
بالعيد ما جدوى هذه الهدى طالما انها تخرق
دائما
وفورما تتوقف هذه المدن يعود الاقتتال الى
يكون اشرس واوسع دكتور الهدنه الماضيه
كانت مخصصه في الاساس لعلاج جرحى جرح
الجيش وجرحى الدعم السريع وذلك لم يتم لم
يتيسر
المواطنون شكوا من ان هذه الهدن
تشهد تعديات كبيره عليهم
جد هذه المره على خط الهدنه هو ظهور حالات
عديده
لاعتداءات جنسيه وثقها المفوض السامي
لحقوق الانسان التابعه المتحده عندما تحدث
عن ان انهم رصدوا اكثر من 50 حاله
جنسيه منها عشرين من 18 الى 20 حاله تمت
في هجوم واحد الجديد ايضا ظهور فيديوهات
مصوره لحالات اغتصاب ارتكبها جنود من
الدعم السريع اشاعه موجه من غضب عاري في
الشارع السوداني من ماده الى اطلاق دعوات
لجمعه الغضب تسير مظاهرات يوم الجمعه
القادمه في العاصمه السودانيه اما بخصوص
الهدنه الهدن كل الهدن التي ابرمت بين
الجيش السوداني
والمتمرديه الدعم السريع حتى هذه اللحظه
لم يستفد منها المواطن في شيء بل دفع
ثمنها غاليا على هيئه اعتداءات
سرقات
هجوم على المنازل سرقه الاساسات والسيارات
واعتداءات اخرى شكرا الدكتور مزمل ابو
القاسم الكاتب المحل السياسي السوداني
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا حيث
اعلنت سلطاتك المواليه لروسيا استهدف
القوات الاوكرانيه وسط مدينه دونيسك
بالمسيرات واوضحت السلطات انها مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين استهدفتا منطقتين في المدينه
مما اوقع دمارا كبيرا
وقال موقع ريبار العسكري الروسي ان القتال
الاعنف مستمر في منطقه اريخوفا في اتجاه
زبالوجيا واشار الموقع الى ان مظاليين
اوكرانيين حاولوا اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه
في الغابات المحيطه بالمنطقه دون جدوى كما
اكد الموقع ان القتال مستمر ايضا على جبهه
في دنيا ولكن دون تغييرات على الارض وان
القوات الروسيه سيطرت على قريه
باتجاه مارينكا بشكل كامل
تساؤلات ترافق المشهد الاوكراني في ظل
عوائق امام التقدم الجيش الاوكراني برا
على اكثر من جبهه وتاخر تزويده بالصواريخ
الغربيه بعيده المدى مما يحقق له افضليه
على الارض وضع جعل كياف تراهن على
المسيرات ضمن ادوات الاستهداف والارباك
حتى في الداخل الروسي وعلى الحدود لكن
غموضا رافق تجدد استهداف موسكو بالمسيرات
خصوصا ما تعلق بمصدر انطلاقها
[موسيقى]
على خط اسلحه وتقنيات المواجهه العسكريه
المتواصله دون توقف بين روسيا واوكرانيا
يدخل سلاح المسيرات بشكل لافت موسكو مره
اخرى عرضه لهجوم بمسيره اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه احبطه متهمة
على منطقه موسكو بثلاث طائره مسيره تم
اسقاطها ليضيف حاكم منطقه موسكو ان الجيش
الروسي اعترض طائرتين كانت تقتربان
للمستودعات عسكريه في المنطقه هذا في
الداخل الروسي اما في دنيا فقد سجلت هجمات
للقوات الاوكرانيه بمسيارات استهدفت مبنى
سكنيا ومنطقتين اخريين وفق سلطات دانياسكا
المواليه لروسيا اللجوء الى المسيرات ياتي
بينما يستمر الهجوم المضاد الذي تشنه
اوكرانيا لاسيام في الجبهه الجنوبيه من
البلاد وسط حديثها عن تقدم عسكري باتجاه
جنوبا من محور زابولوجيا
لكن حسم المعركه على الارض بدا رهنا ايضا
بتحقيق تقدم بريم فعلى امتداده شبهات
دونيتسكو وزابولوجيا وخيرسون لا يبدو ذلك
تحقق للاوكرانيين بالنظر لاحتزام المعارك
على غرار ما حدث في بخموت موقع ريدار
العسكريه الروسي قال ان القتال الاعنف
مستمر في منطقه اوريخوفا في اتجاه
زابولوجيا واشار الموقع الى ان مظليين
اوكرانيين حاولوا اختراق الدفاعات الروسيه
في الغابات المحيطه بالمنطقه دون جدوى ولم
تنقطع مطالب كياف بالحصول على الصواريخ
بعيده المدى تمكنها من احداث اختراق في
الجبهات رغم ما حصلت عليه حتى الان من
منظومه هاي مارس الامريكيه او صواريخ
ستارب شادو البريطانيه وهو ما اثار قلق
وزير الدفاع الروسي وجعل اي تقدم اوكراني
رهنا بالحصول على مزيد من الاسلحه الغربيه
ويبدو غياب ما يكفي من الطائره المقاتله
لتغطيه على اي تقدم عامل حسم اخر لم يتوفر
ضمن ادوات المعركه التي يمكنها مرافقته
هجوم كييف المضاد فلاديمير بوتين قال ان
تعزيز قدره الجيش اولويه بينما تحدث وزير
دفاعه عن ان الجيش الروسي وفي ظروف صعبه
يفعل ما بوسعه ويبذل كل ما لديه لتعزيز
سياده وامن البلاد اما تكثيف كييف استخدام
المسيرات فبدا وفق محللين عسكريين نابعا
من التكلفه الرمزيه لهذا السلاح وقدرته
على احداث ضجيج اعلامي دون التسبب في
الوقت نفسه باحداث تدمير كبير للمواقع
التي يستهدفها ولا تبدو المسيرات وفقهم
بديلا من سلاح الصواريخ حيث كشف رد فعل
الدفاعات الجويه الروسيه على هجوم الطائره
المسيره على موسكو ان هذا النظام يعمل
بشكل فعال وقادر على التعرف على الاهداف
العسكريه للعدو وتدميرها لكن التحدي الذي
بقي يثير تساؤلات يتعلق بمصدر الهجمات
خصوصا ان هجمات الكرملين تبدو انها انطلقت
من مكان يبعد كيلومترات فقط عنه مرجح
فرضيه الهجوم من الداخل وهنا معركه اخرى
قد تجد موسكو نفسها في مواجهتها
الرئيس الروسي وفلاديمير بوتين اكد ان
العمليه الهجوميه الاوكرانيه تشهد هدوءا
في الجبهات بسبب تكبد القوات الاوكرانيه
خسائر فادحه في الارواح والمعدات بحسب
وصفه
في الوقت الحالي نلاحظ هدوءا بسبب تكبد
العدو خسائر فادحه في الارواح والمعدات
يبدو ان العدو يعمل حاليا على تشكيل وحدات
جديده من الالويه التي تكبدت خسائر فادحه
لاستعاده قدراته القتاليه لكنه بالطبع
يخشى تكبد خسائر مماثله في المستقبل ذلك
لن يفقده القدرات الهجوميه فحسب بل سيفقد
الجيش الاوكراني القدرات القتاليه بشكل
عام نرى اليوم ان اوكرانيا لم تستنفذ
قدراتها الهجوميه لديها احتياطيات وهم
يفكرون في كيفيه ومكان استخدامها اعتقد ان
الاعداء لا يملكون اي فرصه وهم يدركون ذلك
واشدد بوتين على ان الثالثه النووي
الروسيه يعد الضامن الرئيسيا لامن بلاده
سنستمر في تطوير قواتنا من كل الجوانب
المهمه الاكثر الحاحا هي تطوير الثالوث
النووي التي تعد الضامنه الرئيسيه للامن
العسكري الروسي والاستقرار العالمي نحو
نصف وحدات وتشكيلات القوات الصاروخيه
الاستراتيجيه باتت مزوده بانظمه يارس
الاكثر حداثه كما يتم اعاده تجهيز القوات
بانظمه صواريخ حديثه براس حربي فرط صوتي
من طراز افونجار وفي المستقبل القريب
ستدخل الخدمه القتاليه صواريخ سارمارت
العابره للقارات الثالوث النووي الروسي
يسمح بضمان الردع الاستراتيجي بشكل فعال
وموثوق والحفاظ على توازن القوى في العالم
بهذا ننهي حصاد هذه الليله